klas tv channel 8 las vegas
where news comes first
oh it's gary it's george yes talk about
a throwback that was our news open
from back in 1987. we're digging through
the archives a little bit this morning
today is channel 8's anniversary sherry
my goodness the tv station turned 68
years young today
nate yeah we are the longest running
news program
in the history of the state of nevada of
course back in 1953
when we went on the air things were a
little bit different photographers used
actual
film had to rush it back to the station
and put it through a film processor
then edit it and clip it together before
it could
air howard hughes there at one point
channel 8 was part of a
quirky billionaire howard hughes empire
he bought the station back in 1968 so he
could
call in at night and give orders about
which movie he wanted to see on the air
or if he had fallen asleep he'd asked
uh everyone to restart the movie for him
that was already playing
yes in those days that was before cable
yeah
you know we're so used to seeing movies
all the time but back then
movies showed overnight on local tv
stations and i think i've heard that
people in las vegas sort of got
used to that happening in some newcomers
would go what happened where
were we didn't we just see that part
that was dvr back in 1916.
it wasn't on your phone dvr in 1960 was
by the station
call master control and get them to
press rewind right that's what somebody
said oh that's just mr hughes
right he used the telephone as his
remote hey i fell asleep let's start
that thing back or move back
okay part of our colorful history 68
years on television
and and the three of us have been on the
show for 68 years as well
sometimes it feels like it sometimes
we've seen a lot of changes here at
channel 8 and we've had a lot of great
people
through our hallways and sitting right
here on this anchor desk and other
anchor desks through the years but
it's a wonderful station and it's so
neat to be
the starting tv station in the state of
nevada and mr hughes's cottage is still
in the backyard yeah and if you listen
carefully
you can kind of hear the the call he's
calling he wants it
he wants us to go back and do the last
segment is not a big fan of going in
there because he's got some
heebie-jeebies when you go in there
they say it's kind of haunted